what happens to wanda by the end of the
film who is that character in the
credits sequence and everyone is asking
where's kang these are the biggest
unanswered questions from doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness
right from the top doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness drops a lot of
intriguing details about how the
multiverse works past mcu installments
like avengers endgame and loki have
explored the idea of variants alternate
versions of characters from different
realities but this film takes things a
step further in the film it's implied
that dreams are windows into other
universes at least insofar as it applies
to magical characters like steven
strange and wanda maximov the movie then
upends this concept with the new
character of america chavez america has
the power to travel through realities
and most of the film's plot revolves
around the desire to control or seize
these powers she also mentions that she
has never located any other versions of
herself in other universes she knows
this both because she's looked but also
because she never dreams do america's
powers have something to do with there
only being one of her
one of the biggest twists in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness is
the introduction of the illuminati on
earth 838 the secret group is hugely
important to the marvel comics universe
a council of powerful figures who guide
world events from the shadows and often
make difficult decisions in the process
the 838 illuminati are a staggering
collection of variants marvel tv
characters previously non-mcu favorites
and popular fan casts it includes black
bolt played by anson mount captain
carter played by hayley atwell an
alternate version of carl mordo played
by chewie telegia four john krasinski's
reed richards and patrick stewart's
professor charles xavier it's an
impressive roster that also leaves a lot
of hanging questions about the future of
the mcu for starters some of the
illuminati members individual origin
stories are left unaddressed what
happened to steve rogers in this
universe and was captain carter's origin
the same as in what if more importantly
the illuminati makes three major marvel
character groups official in the mcu the
inhumans the x-men and the fantastic
four it's unknown how each of them came
to be in universe 838 but it seems
likely that they'll all factor into the
franchise's future perhaps a new
cross-dimensional illuminati could form
or maybe marvel studios fantastic four
and x-men films will take place far away
from earth 616 only time will tell
of course the highlight is patrick
stewart's appearance as professor
charles xavier a role he's played for
decades in the x-men movies that
previously existed outside the mcu while
not explicit stewart's return via doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
could seem to confirm that all those old
x-men movies are canon within the mcu
multiverse nonetheless the other x-men
aren't mentioned at all in this doctor
strange sequel and neither is the word
mutant as of now it's unclear how those
aspects of the franchise will be tied
back into the mcu there are a lot of
options on the table stars of the later
x-men movies could potentially be
brought back as variants alternatively
the main x-men characters could be
completely recast down the line with
those changes being justified by the
multiverse marvel studios and disney
could even continue the fox x-men series
although that seems like an unlikely
option whatever happens it should be
exciting to watch
one of the pieces of lore introduced in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness involves incursions cataclysmic
events where multiple realities are
smashed together earth 616's steven
strange is informed by the illuminati
that his 838 counterpart caused an
incursion by using the dark hold to
dreamwalk a crime punished by a brutal
execution later on doctor strange 616
meets a virgin of himself who has become
deeply corrupted by the darkhold and is
implied to have caused his own
incursions finally at the end of the
film the comics character clea shows up
and tasks strange 616 with fixing an
incursion she claims he caused
none of these events are explained in
detail but they could be in further mcu
installments the end credits of
multiverse of madness proclaim that
doctor strange will return so that next
entry could be wilder than ever doctor
strange 2 spends a lot of time talking
about how uniquely dangerous its
eponymous hero can be and if that theme
is to remain relevant going forward it
would make sense for the incursions he
has caused to be explored in greater
detail
one of the more bizarre moments in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness occurs at the end of the film
when the hero snatches a copy of the
dark hold from his evil counterpart he
then uses the spells within the tome to
dreamwalk into the corpse of one of his
other variants who was buried on earth
616 at the beginning of the film this
doesn't sit well with the spirits of the
dead however who quickly rise from their
realm to a cost doctor strange
fortunately christine palmer is there to
help keep him grounded she reminds him
that he's a master of the mystic arts
and encourages him to use the spirits of
the damned himself he does just that
sucking up all the ghosties into himself
and growing a pair of shadowy spirit
wings on his zombified body it makes for
a fun climax but the movie doesn't do a
great job of actually explaining what
happens has doctor strange always had
the ability to control the spirits of
the dead is it a power granted only to a
zombie form or by the darkhold could any
sorcerer potentially wield this ability
now that all of the dark holes are
supposedly destroyed we may never get
concrete answers to these questions
underlying how powerful the character is
in the end scarlet witch isn't defeated
by doctor strange or wong or america
chavez she's brought down by her own
sense of guilt a fierce realization of
the monster she's become face to face
with her sons in an alternate reality
wanda sees them look upon her with fear
in a redemptive act she brings the
entirety of mount one degor collapsing
down upon itself with her inside
demolishing the ancient dark magic
written there
that's the book of the damned
this destructive act of penitence has a
curious side effect the erasure of every
darkhold from every corner of the
multiverse how exactly wanda manages to
pull off that feat however is unclear
the scarlet witch has the power to alter
reality so it's possible that the
mountain magnified her powers in some
way and allowed her to affect other
universes even then though things don't
quite add up if there are dark holes in
most universes it stands to reason that
there are other versions of mount one
dagor as well couldn't someone from one
of those realities simply transcribe
another book or did wanda's magic erase
the mountains in every universe as well
wanda's demolition of the mount wondagor
temple would seem like a definitive end
to the character that is it would seem
that way if kevin feige hadn't already
confirmed that she'll be back the nature
of her next appearance remains uncertain
however and there are a lot of different
ways it could play out the existence of
the multiverse means that the franchise
could just lean on a variant of the
character one of whom plays a major role
in multiverse of madness given how much
time has been spent building up earth
616's wanda however it seems like a
missed opportunity not to continue her
story in some capacity at the very least
it seems highly unlikely that a
collapsing mountain would be enough to
stop the scarlet witch doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness is basically a
montage of her surviving every
conceivable sort of attack there's no
way a few big rocks would be enough to
keep her down right
oh probably
a lot of the action in doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness involves the
book of vashanti an ancient tome of good
magic and the antithesis of the darkhold
it's believed that the book contains
spells that could stop the scarlet witch
but unfortunately that theory is never
confirmed just as our heroes reach the
book of ashanti wanda destroys it with
her dark magic but is the book of
ashanti really gone the place where it
dwells is referred to as a world between
realities which suggests that there is
only one copy presumably that means
wanda burned the only one in existence
removing it from the multiverse
permanently the truth may be a bit more
complicated however who's to say that
the book didn't whisk itself off to some
other place for safety leaving only the
illusion that it was destroyed that
would be an impressive magic trick
so
this is the magic trick alternatively
it's possible that another copy does
exist elsewhere because the mcu version
of the tome never actually gets used in
the doctor strange sequel it's tough to
theorize too much about what role it
could play going forward at the very end
of doctor strange 2 stephen makes his
way back to earth 616 with a new lease
on life but the last shot before the
first round of credits shows a third eye
open in his forehead similar to the one
worn by his sinister counterpart earlier
in the film there are a few possible
explanations for dr strange's third eye
the eye of agamotto acquired by strange
in his first solo film has a number of
powers in the comics that haven't yet
featured in the mcu the big screen
version of the eye is mainly used to
hold the time stone but in the original
marvel canon it also brings powers of
transcendent vision and knowledge among
other things these abilities often
manifest themselves in the form of a
third eye since agamotto himself is one
of the vashanti in the comics powerful
godlike beings who aid the sorcerer's
supreme and created the book of the
vashanti it's possible that strange's
interactions with the sacred tome or its
opposite the darkhold could have opened
the eye of agamotto up to its true
potential alternatively doctor strange
could have simply reached a new level of
mystical power through the story of
multiverse of madness thus unlocking the
secrets of the eye either way he seems
stronger than ever
the first post-credits scene in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
introduces clea a woman from an
alternate reality played by charlize
theron she approaches the steven strange
of earth 616 and demands that he help
her fix an incursion he apparently
caused in the comics clea is a denizen
of the dark dimension with close ties to
dormammu himself given that her purple
hue resembles dormammu's mcu incarnation
and that the universe she opens a portal
to in doctor strange 2 looks similar to
the dark dimension in some ways it's
likely that this backstory will continue
to hold true of course she makes no
mention of her home or of dormammu
during the post-credits scene so it's
yet to be revealed what the nature of
her character will be in the mcu one
thing of particular importance to note
is that clea ends up marrying doctor
strange in the comics since he seems to
have made his peace with the fact that
he'll never settle down happily with
christine by the end of his second film
the mcu could be building a new love
story between him and clea
while not particularly relevant to the
specific story of doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness kang the conqueror
looms large over the whole film from the
dimension-hopping nature of the story to
the introduction of reed richards there
are tons of plot details that silently
hint at the villain's mcu return at the
end of loki season 1 the god of mischief
finds himself in a severely altered time
variance authority that seems to be run
by kang presumably that means that he
could be active in his conquest by the
events of the doctor strange sequel but
it's possible that he doesn't yet
possess a way to easily travel across
dimensions in that instance america
chavez would be of special interest to
him just as she is to wanda maximov
while it makes sense not to overcrowd
any one movie with too many characters
or storylines kang could nonetheless be
impacted by the events of multiverse of
madness he's set to appear in ant-man
and the wasp quantomania if not sooner
and it should be interesting to see
where the mcu takes him
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]